hey guys welcome back to brand-new V to
Rebecca I'm flora and today we're gonna
be showing off James June and specific
gonna be doing a guide for him today so
basically I covered the beginner and the
advanced moveset there will be
timestamps on screen right now if you
want to cut to those but the way I do
this is the beginner move set is shown
everything in the move set that is on
the list and all that stuff and then the
hero specific stuff while the advance
move set is taking those moves and
making combos so if you already know how
to play Jing you just want to know some
combos skip to the advanced one or if
you want to know everything skip to the
beginner because in the beginner we'll
also be covering guard break punishes
you know parry punishes out of stamina
stuff stuff like that so to get started
sang-jun has four chain attacks the
light light combo the light heavy combo
heavy light combo and heavy heavy combo
you may have noticed some white and
orange colors throughout those moves and
that is because James Jun has
uninterruptible stance on all of his
heavy openers heavy opener means it's
the first attack in the chain and of
course since it's a heavy opener it has
to be a heavy and all of the Jenkins
heavy finishers are also unblockable
which is interesting as well in the in
the finishers are the last move in the
chain so you can have best of both
worlds and do the double heavy combo and
the first heavy being uninterruptible
well the second heavy being unlockable
and having two in the same move the only
downside is that they're heavies and
they're a lot slower but we have ways to
get around that which we'll get into a
little bit later in the video his out of
garden mode is the twofold slash which
can be canceled after the first attack
even though it is easy to parry but if
you do catch the enemy off guard it can
help you flow into some more combos and
stuff like that next is seafoods poise
and it can be activated by going down on
the right thumbstick or if you're
confused it's just like full block or
hidden stance the whole point of this is
to regen stamina really fast even when
fully out because most of his good moves
our zone attacks which eat up lots of
stamina this has a dodge property so you
can use it like in stance be aware you
can be G bead mid move of this and you
can't counter guard break out so try not
to get baited into a guard break the
next is his zone and it's very important
even though it's a very simple slash the
normal zone from neutral starts from his
right but if you do a seafood stance
into a zone it comes from the left and
as well seafood poison to lighten
heavies into seafoods poise and only
with heavies you can actually saw faint
mid swing in to see if who's poised to
little
a little faint or saw faint game into
that move which is cool for some
trickery he also has to parry moves the
dow cheese swirl and choke i believe
they're called the choke is pretty
self-explanatory after a parry he will
choke the opponent and then smack them
after a while if you hold it if near
wall there is a potential wall spot
which guarantees a free top heavy for I
believe thirty seven damage and if the
opponent is out of stamina you can
follow up with an unblockable top-heavy
but this is only when they swing out of
stamina if you choke them and that
brings them down to out of stamina then
they don't fall but if they're out of
stamina before you choke them then they
will fall so keep that in mind he also
has a zone attack parry which is the Joe
cheese swirl simply parry then perform a
zone this is unblockable and comes from
your right now that means he has three
zones the neutral zone the parry zone
and the seafoods poison neutral zone is
from your right the parry zone is
unblockable it also comes from your
right and seafoods is the only zone that
comes from your left so just seeing us
you aren't confused and you can use that
in the later combos now these three
zones can also become chain openers
which means instead of the chain combo
heavy-light you could do one of the
three zones and then follow up with a
white afterwards and it can still be
considered a combo and then his last
moves are his dodge attacks he's
actually the first heavy in the game to
have dodged heavy attacks
I know conker has his shield bash into
light but that is a light attack not a
heavy attack and it can be fainted into
some other moves the mighty sanction is
the - forward heavy any mighty backlash
is the side dodged heavies the mighty
sanction or the dodge forward can be
canceled mid move by either simply
fainting with the faint button or saw
fainted into a shin kick by pressing
guard break and the muddy backlash can
also be canceled mid move by either
fainting with the faint button or soft
fainting into a light from the opposite
direction so if you dodge and do the
dodge move from the right and saw faint
into the light the light will come from
the opposite side which in this case is
to the left and it's vice-versa so if we
dodge to the left into a light it'll
come from the right it so it's basically
reverse for his out of stamina punished
is James Jun off a guard break you know
when you've guard break and throw the
opponent you're only gonna be getting a
top heavy I couldn't get anything after
the after that the bot just kept
blocking the light afterwards so if you
have anything that's better than that
let me know in the comments but for all
I know it's only gonna be a top heavy
which one let you 37 damage but if you
throw them if you do a guard break
throw them right into a wall then you're
gonna be getting a double top-heavy
which the first one is uninterruptible
and then the second one is unblockable
which will give you 82 damage and then
off of a parry it's zone into heavy
which i believe is 60 damage I could be
wrong I think it's like maybe 62 or 63
it'll you'll see on the screen but it's
somewhere definitely in the 60s for
damage now that's over with let's move
it to the events move set moving on and
we now have the advanced move set so the
first move that I like to do is the
might backlash into zone is to get the
opponent to react to your move and it's
very similar to T on DS - heavy move you
could alternatively pair this with the
follow up area attack that can lead into
a zone or a choke depending on your
situation or choice B the way this is
more to bait out the opponent not to
actually swing at them next is parry
zone and too top-heavy unblockable into
zone or vice-versa you could incorporate
the seafood stance into this as well so
instead of fainting at the unblockable
into his own use the seafood poises
hidden stands to cancel the heavy and
follow up at the zone like I said you
can reverse of this so if you want to do
a normal zone then follow that up with a
top-heavy unblockable and then think
that so that they bait out the move
parry it and then do the zone right
after either way works it's still gonna
basically give you the end result you
could alternatively also do this after a
Dodge
once the opponent throws a movie you
dodged back with seafood poise do the
zone heavy unblockable feint into
neutral zone either way it's the same
thing next move is the choke into light
heavy feint and then into zone this is
more for the time when you try to do a
choke movement it doesn't wall splat the
opponent you want to choke them so that
they're usually the low on stamina throw
a light because I believe it's
guaranteed and if it's not it's very
quick so it might be guaranteed just
slightly and then throw another and
throw a heavy cuz it's the light heavy
combo feint that heavy into a zone and
that's your combo next up is the another
choke move except this time you're gonna
wall splat them so choke into wall splat
and then zone or the seafood zone
whatever you want to do now in gameplay
I did the neutral two zones but you can
do a seafood zone just because it's a
different direction to really confuse
the opponent but what I like to do is
choke wall splat zone heavy feint and
then into a seafood zone just because
it's the different directions and it
throws off the opponent these heavy
feint unlockables really get the
opponent to move it's really nice to use
these
and then the last move in the advance to
moveset is going to be the mighty
sanction which is the - forward heavy
but then you feint that into a shin kick
kick them in the shin then do a
top-heavy unblockable or either let it
rip feint it zone or light either way
all four of those options work next
we're gonna be moving on to the feet and
perk recommendations so I haven't had
much time to play with defeats but
judging from what these are these are
the play style that might suit you for
the first feature you're gonna have
against all odds deadly and speed revive
if you're a medic and you like to go
revive people then definitely do speed
revive and then using against all odds
and team fights I personally do not like
deadly I think it's a dumb feat so
either having speed revive in just in
case or if you really like doing
teamfights use against all odds for the
second feat you're gonna have
benefaction or revenge attacks and
inspire and similar to how I don't I do
not like deadly I also do not like
revenge attacks I think it's a dumb feat
so I personally am NOT going to use that
but inspire is also really good for
breach because the amount of minions and
the amount of people in that mode and
benefaction is a little bit iffy and it
depends on your situation if you like to
use the seafood poise a lot then you can
use that and give your teammate some
some stamina region but if not you might
as well just go with inspire to help you
get the breach mode wins the third feet
are all healing based ones soothing mist
heals your allies in this perfect for
teamfights second wind is the standard
health regain that we've had for a while
I believe warden has it and then the
last one gives you health at the start
of the at the start of your respawn so
beefy character like Jang Joon now has
more health I personally prefer second
win because it caught it doesn't cost
that much and it's really easy to
activate this you can do this in
literally in the middle of a fight and I
didn't notice a crazy amount of health
on the spawn health feat but of course
you can obviously use soothing mist if
you're into that as well once again for
big teamfights and then for the force
beats we have fiery barrage phalanx and
fire flask fiery barrage is pretty good
at closing off areas in choke points but
you have to hope that the opponent that
you hit walks in the area that you want
to block and obviously if he has that
more experienced players will understand
what that is and try to walk away as far
as possible making the feet useless fire
flask and failings are old feats of
course I personally love failings
because of the shield increase I'm
pretty sure I'm saying this feat wrong
but it's too late to go back now but I
personally enjoy the shield increased
from it so I'll definitely be using that
in the next and lastly we're going to be
going
in specific perks now I'm not gonna go
into the offensive the defensive that's
just him strict perks that he's going to
beginning and that is remedy Bastion
feline agility ventral barrier last and
bulk up and rising dawn if you have
speed revive then I recommend pairing
this of rising dawn so not only did they
get 75% health on a revive set of 50
you've also reviving them a lot faster
if you're a killing machine and you get
a lot of kills with Jing then definitely
use remedy since it's gonna give you a
lot more extra health per kill and
personally I think a vengeful barrier is
really good in 4v4 cuz revenge comes out
a lot so it's gonna give you a lot extra
points like that so I say that his top
three best are gonna be remedy rising
dawn and vengeful barrier just strictly
from his specific perks ya guys it's
going to be the end of the vid say
hopefully guys did enjoy thank you guys
for coming out to the video hopefully
you guys watch the whole video if you
didn't I completely understand I don't
want to sit through things I already
know so that's why I have the timestamps
at the beginning hopefully you guys did
learn something new about Jing June
hopefully you guys can use this stuff in
game now and you're a lot more confident
with the character let me know if I
helped if this video helped you out at
all I'd love to know your thoughts in
the comments below but that guys like TV
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
I covered the informational side of
foreign without being balance changes
hero updates patch notes leaks all that
stuff about foreign are keeping up
everybody up to date with the news and I
play gladiator and James June gameplay
on the side and once James June releases
in marching with the marching fire
update and October I'll gladly be
playing him a lot alongside gladiator of
course since he is my rep sixty main but
yeah guys my two most recent videos will
be on screen if you guys do want to
check that out with that guys have ever
great yesterday thank you parts in the
video and peace out
[Music]